e aí
o brasil é um país muito extenso muito
diverso existem várias culturas várias
realidades várias particularidades
climas aqui e para ilustrar isso vou
apresentar a história de léo e diana
ambas as crianças da bahia de cinco anos
e que gosta de jogar futebol mas que
tenham muitas diferenças nas suas
realidades ana tinha um sonho de ser
cientista e leo de ser jogador de
futebol quanto é o tinha dificuldades
para ir para escola morava muito longe
às vezes não tinha aula na verdade uma
parte do ano sua mãe tinha dificuldade
de conseguir era mãe solteira que levar
comida para casa a água ana não ana e
escola normal como qualquer criança
em salvador leva do sertão nordestina e
as mães também tinham suas diferenças
enquanto a mãe de ana sonhava que ela
seria uma profissional de excelência e
até um futuro pela frente estava criando
investindo na educação para que ela
tivesse sucesso a mãe de leo ela tinha
acordava todos os dias sem saber se o
seu filho iria sobreviver sem saber se
ele iria se tornar um adulto se ele
teria um futuro ela sabia que a água que
ela dava para ele não era segura mas o
que é que ela ia fazer só tinha aquela
água era aquela nada
ah e por isso hoje mais de 2.3 bilhões
de pessoas sofrem sem acesso a água
potável não só que na bahia no sertão no
brasil mas no mundo inteiro e ana
cresceu sabendo disso estudando isso ela
começou a ver dados como a cada 15
segundos uma criança morre por conta de
água contaminada
e isso é muito triste ela começou a
estudar mais a querer o seu sonho de ser
cientista começou a crescer mais ela
queria mudar o mundo ela queria salvar
vidas ela descobriu que a água da chuva
ela é potável e nessas regiões do
semiárido também tá em que existe um
programa que tem mais de um ponto 4
milhões de cisternas espalhadas no
semiárido que agora as mães com mais de
léo tem água perto de casa não vai ser
mais tão afastado e que essa água de
chuva já apresentaram alta qualidade que
ela na chuva h2oh vinha potável virar
limpinha mas não era bem assim anda no
seu aprofundamento de estudo viu que a
água quando cai na telha da casa ela vai
tirar aquela sujeira de um o gato da
vizinha subiu como eu um ratinho que
achou por lá largou o ratinho lá aquela
água passou e limpou tudo levou para
cisterna
o e aquelas bactérias aqueles vírus
foram se proliferando ali e a água
quando ela consumida dessa forma ela
causa doenças ela continua contribuindo
para que eles dados de a cada 15
segundos uma criança morre queijadas de
dois ponto 3 bilhões de pessoas sem
acesso ao potável no mundo e por isso eu
não sabia que ela precisava fazer alguma
coisa ela precisava criar uma tecnologia
que fosse viável para casas como a de
léo
e ela encontrou uma solução chamada só
diz que nada mais é que botar a garrafa
pet exposta ao sol para que aquela água
da cisterna fique potável muita gente
não acredita que só pode fazer isso mas
ele pode sim quando a gente usa protetor
solar para fazer para proteger nossa
pele do câncer de pele a água não tem
essa essa proteção para as bactérias e
os vírus e eles morrem por conta da
radiação ultravioleta que a mesma que
causa câncer de pele na gente e por isso
essa seria uma solução essa lente todo
mundo poderia usar e ana começou a
pesquisar poxa nunca vi isso aqui no
brasil porque as pessoas não usam que
existem várias limitações dentre elas o
próprio uso da garrafa pet faz com que
liberam substâncias químicas que são
potenciais cancerígenas então longo do
uso é muito difícil e além disso a
própria água ela não muda
oi e a margem para o tratamento de 6 a
48 horas como que as famílias vão saber
quando a água está realmente pronto como
é que elas vão confiar que aquela água
tá tá realmente faltava a metodologia
está funcionando por isso ana aos 15
anos decidi fazer alguma coisa aí que
nasceu o aqualuz que é uma tecnologia a
única tecnologia do mundo voltada para
tratamento de água de cisterna que
aquelas que existem e abundante no
semiárido não só brasileiro mas no mundo
é uma tecnologia muito simples que ela
encaixada diretamente na bomba da
cisterna e faz o mesmo processo que os
olhos água passa primeiro por um filtro
também os olhos não tem um filtro para
barrar qualquer tipo de areia pedaços
daquele ratinho que tava no telhado que
é tipo de asa de mosquito toda
substâncias sólidas que possam estar
naquelas externa para não entrar dentro
da água depois essa água ficar
armazenada exposta diretamente à
radiação ultravioleta do sol não tem
placa solar
a substância química é um processo 100
porcento natural e após duas a quatro
horas que é um tempo muito mais rápido
que o sollys essa o equipamento tem um
indicador que ele muda de cor e aí sim
as famílias as pessoas podem saber que
aquela água está potável e aí voltando a
leo ela cresceu
é mas é ou não e um dia que nós estava
com bastante cd tinha acabado de voltar
do futebol a mãe dele deu água que ela
tinha pegado em um em um poço a 3 km de
casa e ela sabia é o mês que aquela dali
tava um pouquinho diferente ela não
estava muito confiante e léo ficou
doente léo e cinco anos foi levado ao
hospital às pressas no hospital ficava
quatro horas de casa que não tinha
remédio não tinha médicos infelizmente
léo morreu
eu e o léo ele representa uma realidade
de mais de 1.8 milhões de crianças que
morrem todos os anos por conta do
consumo da água contaminada essa
realidade não pode acontecer mais
precisamos mudar precisamos fazer alguma
coisa
e hoje rua luiz já está salvando vidas
de crianças hoje já temos esperanças já
temos crianças que tenham uma
perspectiva maior de estudar de crescer
de mudar sua realidade simplesmente
tendo acesso a água potável que deveria
ser um direito fundamental um direito
humano e é negado para muitas pessoas em
todo mundo por isso eu queria deixar
aqui algum convite para vocês vamos
democratizar o acesso à água potável no
mundo
bom obrigada tá
[Música]